most socialists I think the ones who
have not really thought it through I'm
not talking about the die-hard diehard
well at least most diehards I'm talking
about the people who are in it because
they see a system they were born and
they might maybe their first memory is
September 11th and they remember the
carnage and the chaos and you know it
was had stuff to do about big war
machines and it was about oil and money
and my dad might have lost his job or
the stock market shut down and it was
scary then my next big memory is 2008
and my mom and dad lost everything that
they had worked hard for and had to
start all over again and then
coronavirus hit and they lost everything
this system doesn't work the system is
only rewarding the really powerful and
the rich
[Music]
you can feel there's a certain
excitement right now from AOC and Ilan
Omar and you also have Elizabeth Warren
who's been a little more quiet during
this and Bernie those are the four on
the cover but but with AOC and aloha no
more there's a real frothing at the
mouth the real excitement right now like
see none of it works this is the you
know Bailey had this tweet about late
stage capitalism showing people in lines
at supermarkets in San Antonio what she
always fails to add is that yeah our
stores still get restocked unlike in
socialist countries yeah and that and
that as you said before it's messy
nothing nothing in a free society is
absolutely perfect but yes I do see that
the mask is dropping now and and so that
leads me to know there are they really
just communists actually that the next
mask that drops is the socialist mask
meaning that they won't even have to you
know it the system no so this is
something that I clear up in the first
chapter of the book communism is not the
bad one if you were actually look at the
theories of Marx communism is the utopia
we've switched these it was the Soviet
Socialist Republic okay
it's the socialist side that is that is
the scary side the the communism only
happens when we all live in a happy
commune and we're all saying oh you know
what I'll give you my stuff don't worry
about it and there's no big boss
there's no guns because you don't need
it because everyone has come to this
this communist or community ax and we
all want to be there so communism is the
Utopia socialism is the step between
when you have capitalists and then you
have the people who say I want this
utopia it's this middle part well you're
gonna have to do something to convince
these people who like capitalism that
you want to be over here and so you
slowly drag them in piece by piece and
then at some point
you just have to shoot all the other
people that don't agree with it so we
can get to the happy place right so this
is what they're not communists they are
brutal socialists that are willing to
kill willing to do whatever it takes
because the ends justify the means I
mean this is what I keep describing as
this is Thanos from The Avengers movies
what did he have to do yeah it is wipe
wipe out half the people in the universe
to create yeah the Utopia and as he said
yeah I'm the good guy because I was the
only one brave enough to do it and can I
ask you something Dave you live in
Hollywood do you people even watch some
of the stuff that they make every
obvious I especially when it comes to
Marvel I watch these things and I'm like
right I mean it's not just me right
you're seeing that this is making the
freedom kind of message here it's kind
of making all of the conservative or the
libertarian point you're right I don't
I don't do they read do the vibes leave
it at that do they read well you know
what I think I think you know this as
someone that's been around the block you
know a lot of the people here in
Hollywood which is which is very much
changing right now and I think after
Corona the the idea of celebrity and
these big-budget things I think this is
all gonna change but you know most of
these people privately of course they're
capitalists and more libertarian minded
in everything else they push nonsense
and a confused message while in their
own lives what do they want to do more
than anything else they want to be free
they want to earn their money they want
to spend it freely but they push a
message to everybody else it's like most
of our politicians that's just counter
to everything that the way they actually
act can you believe it Glenn could you
actually believe that it's a you know
it's amazing I have I have talked to
some studio heads so these are the these
are the big bosses and they are
definitely capitalists and they said if
Bernie Sanders is the guy all of us are
going to be voting for Donald Trump
we'll never say that because all the
actors and actresses there they all
believe in this crap but they'll kill
this industry he would kill this
industry and so I know there are some
capitalists out there they're not
they're not libertarians or
conservatives but they do like their
money and they know what socialism does
exactly all right so if you're gonna
argue with the Socialists I'm gonna ask
you the number probably the number one
question that I get asked when I go to
college campuses which is how do you
even initiate the conversation not if
you're going back right not if you're
Dave Rubin but if you're a young kid on
a college campus and the the terrible
ideas that you write about here are
taking root and many of your friends
have subscribed to them and you just
want to talk to them about freedom a
little bit some of this but they are
automatically gonna call you a Nazi in a
racist and all of that stuff what is a
trick have you learned any tricks
throughout this that would allow the
conversation - you know that's [ __ ]
yes yes so that was a key word a key
word Dave trick it cannot be a trick it
cannot be a smooth move let me let me
put this in I know you're agnostic or in
it are you an atheist or an agnostic
Glenn you're gonna really enjoy this
other book I have sitting here because
I'm going to talk about some things in a
new way I would say all right yeah I
would say I would say I had functional
I'm a functional believer I would say at
this point sort of in the Jordan
Peterson sense of okay good yeah for you
okay that's good yeah okay well let me
just talk to you here about Jesus sit
for a second and and one thing that I
don't like about Christian Church let me
just go and just take on my church
we have missionaries that go out and I
don't mind the idea of missionaries and
you know talking into people about
things but what I what bothers me is how
do we get people to talk about Jesus how
do we get people to get closer to
baptism I don't know that sounds icky
how about we love people and we listen
to people and we seek out what they are
looking for in their life what are they
seeking most socialists
I think the ones who have not really
thought it through I'm not talking about
the die-hard diehard well at least most
diehards I'm talking about the people
who are in it because they see a system
they were born and they might maybe
their first memory is September 11th and
they remember the carnage and the chaos
and you know it was had stuff to do
about big war machines and it was about
oil and money and my dad might have lost
his job or the stock market shut down
and it was scary then my next big memory
is 2008 and my mom and dad lost
everything that they had worked hard for
and had to start all over again and then
coronavirus hit and they lost everything
this system doesn't work the system is
only rewarding the really powerful and
the rich my folks struggled and I don't
want to I don't want to live my life
like my folks did believing in this
nonsense that if I heard somebody talked
to me about that I could relate to them
and I would agree with almost everything
they just said now we can have a
conversation because instead of
approaching them and trying to win the
argument I'm trying to ask them
questions to get to understand their
perspective how did they get there don't
talk to me about systems how did you get
here what are you really looking for and
if you're looking for the workers of the
world unite I move on if you're looking
to find a better way to live in harmony
live some natural principles live in
ways that will actually work and I don't
see this system is working okay great
I'm with you so now what are the
problems let's let's separate the baby
from the bathwater is there a baby in
that bathwater I think there is you may
not so let's define what that baby is
and separate it from the bathwater yeah
I guess the only problem is that well of
course it makes sense but I guess the
only flaw unfortunately is that we have
just so many young people that talk
about workers of the world unite or just
the evil patriarchy or just the the
simple versions as opposed to a complex
human version of understandable things
that you just laid out there that it
makes that conversation just hard to
have well it makes it hard to have in a
crowd but nothing is ever really solved
in a crowd if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlists all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell